[Music]
[Applause]
e
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
he
hey everyone welcome back to the lobby
gam spots weekly live show here in San
Francisco California I'm your host Mike
mahardy here with Pete Brown hey buddy I
finally got you to stopped playing Zelda
before we went live that was you yes oh
we're going to talk more about Zelda
later uh with the master trials DLC
master of Trials master of Trials DLC
which has the trials of the sword and
master mode did I get that right you got
it yes sweet uh we'll be talking more
about that today as well as crash insane
Trilogy uh Star Wars Battlefront 2 loot
system and weather that game is pay to
win uh to talk about those things we
also have the normal cast Cy pagy hello
and Rob Hanley hi uh we just got done
here in the US with a long Fourth of
July weekend at a what five 4 Day
weekend mhm yeah uh appropriate for the
fourth uh Cy you went to Anime Con anim
Expo yes sorry yeah Anime Expo in Los
Angeles it's at the convention center so
it was really weird to go back after
just being there for E3 oh that sucks oh
wow yeah so it was like it's very
different um West is almost empty and
it's just like it's a totally different
experience but basically uh the biggest
takeaway is like dragon balls everywhere
which is amazing to me that series is is
still going really strong and there were
tons of cosplayers and every Booth had
there was like a giant Shen long in the
ceiling um so we'll have galleries of
that up on Gamespot later let's pretend
I don't know anything about anime why is
Dragon Ball does am I right in saying it
seems to have a Resurgence lately yeah
so Dragon Ball super um started airing
and that's the first first uh original
Storyline by the Creator in 18 years so
um I mean but in the interim it was
still you know it's it's amazing that
people are that's people still care I
guess um because having to wait 18 years
and you know playing a series of games
that weren't very good or something now
we have Dragon Ball fighters fighters Z
or Fighters however you want to say it
um coming out so we have a lot to get
excited about with Dragon Ball but all
of those fans from the Dragon Ball Z era
are just coming back in full force which
was really cool to see for a lot of them
Dragon Ball Z was like the first anime
that they could really latch on to get
excited about so I think that's just
persisted you know game looks gorgeous
the new one coming out when does that
actually release um I can't I can't
remember yeah sometime early fall I
believe um but if you saw there's like a
video year early next year says the
voice of God what are we thinking of
every other game every other game that's
coming out in the fall um uh one of the
cool things about that is it was like
frame for frame from the manga like I'm
a really big uh Dragon Ball Dragon Ball
Manga fans a lot of the supers were
taken frame for frame which is so cool
like that that game is so faithful to
the original um like the source material
cool I'm really excited for it yeah you
cover a ton of anime manga stuff here uh
overall takeaways from Anime Expo I
wasn't really paying attention so we
some bullet points uh foly coly 2 and
three are coming in uh next year um they
separate series continuations of fly COI
or flcl um and the pillows are doing the
music again which is really cool a lot
of people are really really excited
about that if you're familiar with fly
kly at all um that's a it's you know a
really really beloved series kind of
like a Coming of Age sort of thing um
and so they're doing two new separate
Seasons they aren't like it isn't like
season two and season 3 it's like two
they're almost Series yeah and so you
can watch the trailer it's up now but
cool awesome well uh as always is if you
are joining us in the YouTube twitch
Gamespot chats welcome we have that
right up so uh feel free to participate
throughout the show got a couple news
items I want to get through and a
giveaway we didn't do one last week
because we were still kind of recovering
from E3 uh this week in in uh honor of
the new Spider-Man movie which is
apparently really good I have not seen
yet um we have a Spider-Man theme
giveaway we have a Disney Infinity
pretty old Disney Infinity uh black
Spider-Man black suit Spider-Man we have
a Funko plushy there in the middle and
then uh we have a fig hanging upside
down Spider-Man uh yeah so as always
we're going to tweet that and then you
can uh if you don't follow Gamespot on
Twitter then retweet that and we can uh
get that out later this week we'll pick
a random winner uh Jean Luke if when you
get the chance our chat just went down
so nobody chat right now I'm just
kidding we can't see you we can't see uh
but anyway I do want to get through uh
some news items quick uh on the positive
side of things we have uh a destiny
charity raised a million dollars for St
Jude's Children's Hospital uh the stream
took place at Guardian Con in Florida uh
actually just finished up last week June
30th to July 1st um last year they did
$560,000 but apparently it's BEC a big
thing cuz they almost doubled that this
year they raised a million to go to St
judee's Children's Hospital uh also yeah
it's really good uh What did we raise
for Char extra life like
$6,000 you guys got us beat it was more
than more than 10 yeah right over 10
yeah it was over 10 like 20 the cool
thing about we're coming for you
Guardian con the cool thing about
Guardian con is they raised a million
dollars before the con even started oh
wow so they did they did like a pre like
a week before of streaming with like
different stream incentives I think one
of the incentives was like oh you get to
be in my RAID group for like year one of
Destiny too um and so that probably
helped a lot of the donations cool uh
also as far as Mass Effect fact
Andromeda goes there's some confusion
around this uh DLC report some Facebook
post surfaced from Sinclair networks and
then uh Kotaku had been reporting saying
like uh three sources that worked on the
project were saying there will be no DLC
that had been canceled but then there
was an up update uh and then EA told us
that they have never worked with
Sinclair networks uh they didn't clarify
whether there would be DLC in the future
but for people who had read some of
those reports saying there won't be DLC
those are actually not confirmed just to
clear that up uh why people care that
much about DLC for this game is the part
I want to know I'm just kidding sorry um
but in other BioWare news this is kind
of smaller but I figured it was relevant
uh Mike llaw creative director on the
Dragon Age series if he played
Inquisition back in 2004
Dragon Age 2 which was how long ago
before that does anybody know yeah and
the Dragon Age Origins which I really
like uh he was saying they are hiring a
ton of people so uh in the wake of
Andromeda I wonder how much they would
actually talk about Dragon Age if they
do I'm sure they'll do something new it
sold really well in 2014 but of course
now they have Anthem as well uh coming
from BioWare but so we might be seeing
something from Dragon Age in the nearish
future so keep an eye out for that if
you're a BioWare fan uh and yeah cool so
that's all the news for the week that
it's kind of slow week uh in general
it's been kind of slow aside from Zelda
DLC which if you're just joining we will
get to later uh but first Pete you
reviewed crash insane get into it M yay
let's get into this you gave it a six
out of 10 I did have a little bit of
backlash uh just a little which is weird
because everything I see on Twitter from
people who like really like I don't know
they said the first game is really bad
now second one is probably the high
point third is not is that the is that
is that your takeway yeah the second one
it seems to have just the best little
like variety by the time you get to the
third it's just yeah it's interesting
though because everybody seems to
acknowledge that like one of the games
in that trilogy the remaster Trilogy is
good yet they still think that like it's
a faithful homage to the original games
which I guess like we wanted to talk
more about after I get some of your
thoughts on the review uh whether this
needed to exist outside of nostalgia but
uh but anyway first I want to ask you so
overall kind of broad Strokes if people
haven't read your review or watched it
uh what do you think
um I think as far as a you know a
remaster remake goes you couldn't really
ask for this game to look any better um
you know vicarious Visions did a really
good job of just sort of modernizing
what crash is but crash is also a very
simple game and one that I don't think
really stands a test of time um I think
if you didn't play Crash Bandicoot and
you didn't have Nostalgia for this and
you started to play it today you would
probably think well this is a pretty
simple game doesn't really do anything
interesting yeah you know crash has
great personality um some of the level
designs are okay but by and large it's
it's a very simple game um and one
that's Antiquated at this point his fur
looks too real for this kind of
Animation it looks weird it's a it's a
bit strange I mean it looks super modern
but it plays like an old game yeah yeah
uh and then I I did want to talk just in
general because uh I think it was last
year Jean Luke when the Bioshock uh
remastered collection came out uh he was
saying like when there are certain cases
where in like with those games sometimes
remasters can hurt a game The Things
They sacrifice and whether they actually
are faithful or are too faithful in this
case did you think that there was an
opportunity or a missed opportunity to
maybe expand on the original games
formulas obviously that wasn't really
what they were going for but um yeah I
mean if you think if you just want to
judge the game based on what the
developers were going for I they did a
great job of doing that but I but I
think you know you say does it remain
too faithful well I think maybe in some
parts you know like one of the things
that people have been giving me crap
about is that in my review I say like
there are points in this game where it
just like you can make it super far into
a level and there's one jump that's just
like super super like the the constraint
for Success versus failure is really
tight and you can lose you know a lot of
lives very quickly uh so people said oh
the game's too hard six out of 10 well
no but I do think it's uneven at points
and that was the the point that I was
trying to make is that this game just
kind of very abruptly int introduces
something that just seems in congruous
with everything either before it or
after it in the same level um and I
think some of that could have been
evened out it's not a matter of I
couldn't beat the game it's a matter of
wow this is this is not consistent and
it just seems almost like an accident uh
rather than something that's been
thoughtfully designed uh from top to
bottom uh Filipe idar in the twitch chat
was saying it is weird that they updated
the physics but not the level design is
that accurate is that how you felt uh
well the level design they have not the
physics I'm not quite sure what they're
referring to I do know that like yeah
you can use an analog stick now um in
addition to the d-pad um which I
actually felt was kind of strange
because a lot of these level designs
were created for uh you know this sort
of very clean controls of a d-pad where
you need to you know step accurately to
the right or the left or forward or
backward depending on the mission you're
in because it could be you know you're
running from a boulder and you have to
very accurately navigate Pathways that
get more narrow yeah um and I so I
thought the analog controls were like a
nice touch in some areas but almost like
not worth using the whole time yeah um
which thought it's a little strange but
the physics specifically I don't know
someone said they unified the jump
physics across all three games kind of
like like I don't know like a recent
thing I did Metro Redux they took like
the last Light physics and graphics and
implemented them in 2033 I can I can
understand that it's been so long since
I played The Originals that I I just
didn't notice that that change and you
wonder what went into that decision when
you're thinking about like how those
physics originally affected two or
three's level design maybe or like the
actual hit box detection with the boxes
or enemies what not this the detection
I'm sure that that that's fine but it's
more or less the measurement of you know
the the layout of a level right like how
things line up and the distance between
them and the timing required to hit
those yeah um like it's it's a fine game
and and you know I'm seeing everyone who
really loves crash they still really
like this um I liked crash when I you
know when it came out and the first
three games were still relevant um I
don't know I just I I thought it was
okay it's tough to say because you would
you know you uh if you're a huge fan of
the trilogy wouldn't be a bad thing if
they just completely remade it right
like res evil remake is one of the
better remakes ever I always cite that
that's a different thing right they're
not just remastering it they're actually
kind of rebooting it a little bit or
Ratchet and Clank last year on PS4 they
took the original game but they borrowed
a bunch of really good aspects from the
later games from the future Trilogy and
from just the rest of like up Your
Arsenal going commando there's so many
like innuendo titles in that series I
love Ratchet and Clank that last remake
never played any of those games uh prior
but like R FL is one of my favorite
games and I agree that's it was a very
they cherry-picked what worked right
like and and then also threw in like
really great controls like I I forget
what iteration you were telling me where
they where they finally steered away or
steered towards the like um aiming while
while like strafing and jumping and
stuff like that like they didn't have to
do that it was pure third person like uh
From ratchet's perspective in the first
game and then in going commando the
second one you had the option to turn on
strafe and reticle and the third one
yeah up Your Arsenal that was the Bas
but yeah they UPG they updated that to
actually not be a pure third person game
anymore in the first game but you you
yeah like you as someone who had never
played the first game got into it
because of that remake last year oh
totally um yeah and just you know I
think crash um had like the similar like
you know um as far as showing the really
nice blending of motion and motion blur
um I don't know like that makes
everything worthwhile and you know that
you know you look at some like crash and
like you see that and it looks great but
like you know hearing Peter talk about
how it felt you know they they did not
update the control right like no no no
they did update the controls but the the
level design wasn't there to meet the
updated controls okay I understand yeah
um but you know again another key point
to understand is like something like
Ratchet and Clank even if they just did
a remaster right like those games were
still they they came out at a time when
3D platforming action had kind of been
figured out Crash Bandicoot was made
when those things hadn't really been
figured out and standards have changed
quite a bit um yeah right well that's
that's the question right when you're
going back to something like Gears of
War a couple years ago with the Ultimate
Edition before 4 came out like that's
that's always the challenge with
remasters like do you want to stay
faithful or do you want to update it for
modern palletes in a way that like it's
not just you know like rose tinted
glasses you're actually playing
something that's fun with everything
that's come out after the original
release like uh I don't know CI you
reviewed ukulele earlier this year and I
know you're a big fan of first and
foremost banjo tuille but also kazui
kind of to a lesser extent um but
ukulele I think is another prime example
of 3D Platformers are kind of you know
outside of Mario games and I mean
Ratchet and clang to certain extent and
I'm sure I'm missing a bunch but they've
kind of faded to the periphery as
opposed to what they were you know at
the Advent of 3D uh ukulele did it feel
that kind of game feel as relevant or
even like kind of like did you feel like
it was dated because they were sticking
too closely to the original 3D platform
or formula yeah it definitely felt dated
I think the the biggest issue with
ukulele is that they were trying to meet
the fans where they were instead of kind
of bringing the fans to something you
know new or invent vve so it was very um
you know run-of-the-mill it felt like
banjo kazui with a reskin and a you know
a more finicky camera so um there were a
lot of things that didn't work for me um
there were a lot of things that were fun
I do like the I mean I had the the
collectathon kind of thing is is
something that that was nostalgic for me
but I think that they just didn't
execute it well because it was so close
to what I expected from banjo kazou like
I didn't have to try very hard to to go
through the levels because I was like
well I've played banjo kazui a thousand
times I know exactly what I'm looking
for and I know what all the secrets are
already they didn't bring anything new
and the camera was a mess which sucks
cuz that's kind of what can make or
break a 3D platformer they to be fair
they did patch it out but when I
reviewed it it was it was pretty wonky I
think this is my gameplay even where I
was like I don't I can't even see I look
like I'm really bad at this kind of game
because the the um the the it's like the
depth perception is off or something and
so this is another case where like if I
misjudged a jump or like um there were
times where like I couldn't get high
enough like a platform looked like I
could reach it from you know down below
but then I would jump and I couldn't
reach it stuff like that um and so the
dated aspects combined with the
technical missteps just made it um kind
of an
unfortunate it looked like they finally
like they had a uh a pretty big like
patch or update for this game I think
last week and the one that stuck out to
me because I remember playing this was
something that was really frustrating
was that gibberish noise that they kept
making yeah like I that was like that
was almost a deal breaker alone just
that that constant babbling was so loud
and obnoxious that maybe worked you know
in the last games like but now it's just
super annoying so anyways the update I
think you were able to like skip it or
turn it off or something yeah they did
update it where
you could um like go really quickly
through dialogue or turn it off there's
there's some sort of option but honestly
like I have no desire to really revisit
it now that I'm done with the game yeah
Michael ham actually went down to Irvine
uh recently at blizzard to play
Starcraft remastered uh now Starcraft 2
has how many expansions now three is it
I think two or three uh and that was
another case where we saw you know the
uh remaster was kind of announced and of
course now it's like uh actually you
know it's been is g to fit modern
graphics and everything it still looks
pretty faithful to the original game but
uh you know it's kind of picking
Michael's brain and it sounds like it's
you know doing enough to actually you
know kind of tap into that Nostalgia but
also still feel like a game that can be
played today yeah and you know you have
to wonder because RTS is another one of
those genres which there's still good
RTS games coming out last year uh
Warhammer 40,000 dawn of War 3 God that
title's a mouthful that was actually a
really good game I played that and I
liked it a lot I know Dave J over in the
UK plays a lot of RTS games still but I
maybe it's just difference of genres and
like Pete like you said crash was at the
Advent of like kind of 3D platform you
right was Nag's first outing uh if I'm
not mistaken far as I'm aware yeah and
they're still trying to figure things
out and of course you know like before
they got to Jack and Dexter and then
there's some like platform aspects to
Uncharted but you have to wonder whether
crash the insane Trilogy actually there
was much reason for it to come out
outside of nostalgia like yeah is it
relevant anymore that that kind of goes
back to my point like if this game came
out it wasn't called Crash Bandicoot I
don't think people would give two shits
yeah I played crash in Uncharted 4 and
that was enough for me I don't know any
other remasters that I'm missing that
like might like like I said uh there's a
really good video on Gamespot Jean Luke
did about the Bioshock collection uh and
how those kind of almost like hurt the
original games in terms of uh updating
them for 2016 but uh you can look to 3DS
the the work on Star Fox 64 and 3DS and
in particular is really good in terms of
remaster um and those same or Ocarina
and as well but starf Fox 64 stood out
more Majora's Mask I was really happy
because they updated the bosses so it
was yeah so but it was still F like it
was modernizing it enough to where like
they fixed the problems that that game
had with bosses but also it was still
faithful to the original like I thought
they did a really good job with Major's
mask oina like just like even just think
about the water temple how they updated
that and move the iron boots to an item
slot as opposed to equipment so you have
to pause all the time really yeah yeah
that was a really like it's a very small
change that doesn't affect your like
your you know whatever your fond memory
is but it it greatly enhances the
experience returning to it and then Wind
Waker HD is another example of like
adding the Swift sale and getting rid of
that really frustrating in sequence um
like the tri Force thing yeah where
you're you know hunt you have to like
sail around and it takes forever um
adding the Swift sale was really smart
and that's something that like that I
was really frustrated with in like Omega
rupey and Alpha Sapphire for Pokemon
like they didn't update any of the
travel and you have to it's just so
frustrating it's like so bogged down at
the end yeah and I like I like talking
to you about this stuff Pete because you
as someone who like puts a lot of time
into looking into like game preservation
and you collect a lot of older games and
everything so there's always that fine
line between you know is this game good
today no but it's still faithful like
maybe preservation of the original game
it's kind of it must be a fine line to
walk I mean I know you're not making
these games but from your perspective as
someone who plays a lot of them and
collects a lot of the original versions
yeah I was wondering like what they were
probably thinking when they were doing
the crash insane Trilogy like they've
gone so far to make it look so good and
then they just adhere to again dated
sort of levels and and stuff like that
like they must part of them must have
felt like can't we just do something new
with it you know like yeah maybe we'll
see that I mean maybe the work they've
done is just the foundation for for
something else cool uh yeah if you're
watching right now or after the fact or
listening on iTunes you can go uh read
Pete's full review for the crash insane
Trilogy on Gamespot uh Rob just last
week you were uh watching a Battlefront
2 video that kind of caught my eye uh
there's loot crates coming up in
Battlefront 2 when it launches in
November uh but also some slightly more
possibly concerning aspects to this
progression system uh first off lay the
basis for what is going on in this
game's progression the basis well uh
Battlefield the foundation kind sure
sure sure the battlefield one had lot
crates but they were purely cosmetic
this time around they are um well
they're the star cards the powerups that
you got from like the previous iteration
did you mean to say Battlefront one did
I say what did I say well I was
comparing Battlefield one which was
purely cosmetic you know here is now the
progression with like Star cards and
so how do I do this okay so basically
sorry I haven't spoken in a while just
to clarify spoken in a while let me so
let me I'll set up real quick just just
to clarify for people watching this
b-roll is from I believe they it was a
disclaimer like a paid a YouTuber yeah
his name uh YouTuber just so you know
yeah the YouTuber his name his name is
Battlefront updates so that tells you
anything so here you see basically these
different types of cards so you you get
a loot which you get through credits
credits you you earn through matches um
what you get from a Loot Crate can be
anything from Star cards which are
abilities each class has two uh specific
you know like permanent abilities uh and
then you have an option basically to
swap out with one of these uh earned
star cards you get through a Loot Crate
uh you can also get credits apparently
and uh crafting parts so if I were to
get uh for instance like an assault
training uh Star Card which boosts
boosts my health every kill I get there
are different like Fashions of that star
card so I could get a common card um a
uh uncommon to rare to Epic um epic
being like for the example given here I
think was like uh an epic Star Card
which I can upgrade with crafting Parts
um an epic would give me gr me like 40
Health if I for every kill opposed to
like common which is 20 MH
so the point being that like you
randomly get like this assault card
right and I can put that for a a
specific class um I can upgrade that
with crafting parts that I can get
through dupes or again like just
randomly through these uh loot crates so
if I get a duplicate Loot Crate I can
convert that to crafting parts and then
I could basically manually like pick
that said Star card and upgrade it to
Epic I think the problem however is that
the other uh uh Rarity
um card is legendary legendaries are
purely random and through loot crates
which like a lot of games have legendary
items but they are cosmetic right like
uh OverWatch has a lot of higher tier
Aesthetics for each character but again
they're not going to affect the gameplay
just what you see so that's where this
becomes a little bit potentially
problematic unless there's something
huge we're not seeing because you can
pay to get legendary items ostensibly
through paying for credits with real
world money so that's what you're that's
what you have to imagine right through
micro transactions that like there will
be legendary loot crates that will grant
me or guarantee me a legendary Star Card
they're they're random but of course the
more obviously the more money you pay
the more likely you are to get them
through the system so you could be
playing someone that instead of paying
like $100 to eventually get this
specific uh Han Solo skin you're going
to be playing against someone who paid
$100 to get this specific ability that
can wreck everybody or standing around
yeah and this is all hyp those are like
hypothetical situations but that's what
it sounds like this is moving toward
because you actually pay for abilities
and powers in game in a multiplayer
setting that can potentially be
imbalanced by real world money yeah I
mean and it's a it's a matter also of
balancing these cards right so like in
another video this guy had of like three
he put out he was showing like um I
believe it was like a like a stealth
card but basically it would like double
he was he was comparing like the Epic to
like the common and it was pretty
significant as far as the melee damage
it was doing it was like like opposed to
like without the card it was like takes
like four hits or like three hits to
kill someone and this guy was doing it
in like two oh my god um but that you
know that can be balanced I'm sure
they're they're constantly already doing
that but yeah I mean it's it's
concerning like you know again you said
it like you know I'm all four loot
crates for Cosmetics like that's fine
but I get I wonder if one of the issues
I was telling someone this is like maybe
they like they would would have
definitely you know maybe they would
have loved to have done like a Cosmetic
System but you think about Star Wars and
the blandness with like just you know
original trilogy Stormtroopers like I
really don't want to see you know pink
tiger skinned clone troopers walking
around like for yourself yeah we'll see
about that you know you could do you
could do you know purely weapons uh say
like Scopes maybe like or maybe some
like different grips I mean but to what
extent is that
is that going to work for them is that
going to give them money because they
had to implement I guess some kind of
microtransaction if all of their DLC is
going to be free it's interesting
because it's more of a bummer because it
seems like Battlefront 2 was moving
toward what made Battlefield one good in
terms of its progression right you get
uh weapon attachments and everything
through ingame currency but it wasn't
like something that completely
imbalances you and gives you extra
abilities but EA I think you know in the
early 2000s kind of had this image of
being a money grubber right with
microtransactions and everything and
it's seems like now nobody has paid to
win because of the image it would the
damage it would doe to their game's
image it seems like it's so weird that
they might even be considering this at
this point yeah I mean I I
think ultimately solutions to this that
would would help the situation is if I
am like what you don't want is you don't
want to just like not have any form of
controlled progression right say I'm
like obsessed with flying and by the way
all the ships and vehicles say say Rob
might be obsess I am so uh Vehicles all
also now have apparently uh uh like
weapon slots or like modifications supp
posted to last time like you can kind of
customize your um vehicle like you can
be Battlefield one with skins and
loadouts but say like as long as I if I
can focus onto a task or like a role or
a class MH and I can be guaranteed say
maybe loot crates that are like specific
to Vehicles like oh this one's going to
have like uh a nibo starf fighter skin
because I was flying a lot of that or
maybe it's going to be a weapon load out
for that hopefully that is a way I think
the the progression can kind of like
outshine from the randomness you know
like if it's kind of generalized loot
crates I I I think that could be a
possibility but I don't know well
Injustice 2 did something recently work
because you can unlock a couple a few
new abilities for each character but
they're uh if you don't get them
randomly through a Loot Crate you can
also just unlock them without paying
anything at levels 15 and 20 I believe
for each character or something and you
unlock those abilities so but there's
also ranked matches where those don't
like certain things don't your loot and
your uh Loadout does not affect anything
it's just the base fundamental stats for
each character same with Destiny iron
Banner actually takes into into account
your loot and so you could you know
presumably have worse loot than someone
else there's specific game modes where
that loot plays into the game so to me
that would be an easy way for
Battlefront 2 to balance it like you can
play this playlist or this game mode
where you can have these pay to win
abilities the best loot if you don't
want that you have the equivalent of
like a ranked match where everybody's
playing at the sure the same level
playing field but outside of Destiny I
can't think of many shooters that do
something like that but it would it
would make sense for this game like it
would be an easy way for them to say oh
if you don't want to do this where
someone could pay $100 for this
legendary ability or whatever or this
cannon slot on this tank then go play
the standard Team Deathmatch playlist
with no Heroes so maybe I hope they're
doing something like that want so bad
yeah uh it seems like that would be the
easiest way to just ify what seems like
a Pay to Win thing like maybe more will
come out and I'll you know I'll have to
like eat my words but that's what it
seems like right now especially after
that detailed video you guys can go
watch it it was Battlefront
updates Channel YouTuber but it's right
now it makes me a little more worried
than I was because I was really looking
forward to how Battlefield one another
dice title was influencing Battlefront
yeah and like we were talking a couple
weeks ago about like the the um Heroes
system not being like just a random
token
kaks I was hoping that loot would be
more like like you were saying rob like
weon cation like oh if I want like an
extended mag or whatever it is like I
don't know that that it wouldn't be that
but like whatever whatever uh it could
be like a a scope because if you like
sniping maybe you want to customize your
weapon and that would be different than
oh this thing can kill you in two hits
instead of 15 and now I've just won the
match for my team are you even think
about what like we we kind of left I
felt like E3 with like a pretty positive
outlook on even like Yeah you mentioned
Heroes like oh it was actually kind of
easy or or um easier to take down Darth
Maul or like one of one of these Heroes
Heroes will
now apparently you can customize these
and put legendary cards on them so they
take um less damage you know or or
deliver more damage like gez that's
going to be fun one of these guys with
like all legendary cards as Darth Maul
just wrecking shop like that is
a worry and can easily be a concern yeah
but then you see that advertis says pay
$50 and kill Darth M E's year they
wouldn't say that but that's what it
sounds like you could do uh yeah so I
guess I'm personally concerned we'll see
what happens with it if they can figure
out a way to make it a little more of a
balanced playing field hopefully or
maybe I just hopefully you know just you
know need to hear more about it to
understand it but right now uh the
question was is it pay to win and it
seems like it might possibly be
um might hear more about it we will hear
more about it as the game approaches its
November release uh I'm still kind of
looking forward to it for sure the story
mode especially but we'll see how the
progression everything goes um cool all
right I think that's it we don't have
anything else to talk about what did you
do all week all right Zelda Master
trials I think I got that right master
of Trials what that's such a master of
Trials DLC came out for Legend Zelda
breath of the Wild on Nintendo switch it
launched Thursday Thursday night at like
9:00 p.m. Pacific and we you we had like
a fat it was weird the the storage size
comp I think like it was like bigger
than the a couple gigs I think from Wii
opposed to like I don't know 100 me
megabytes or something like that I want
to talk about it in two kind of separate
separate I don't I don't care how big
the file size is um I want to talk about
it uh as far as what's changed with like
across the board and then we'll get more
into Master mode itself cuz from what
you guys have told me kind of a a big
kind of I was playing Metro last Light
recently in Ranger mode makes it a
different game Far Cry Primal Fallout 4
all have these survival modes and it
kind of sounds like Master mode changes
the entire game and how you think about
Hyrule um but first I want to talk about
just general discussion about tries of
the sword and just the new armor and
masks which seem to be the big changes
and heroes path we can talk a little bit
about about that so those seem to be the
big changes outside of uh Master mode so
first off Tri of Sword rob you finished
it at least on normal difficulty did you
finish it not yet I'm on the second set
so you're not as good as Rob did you
finish it one third is good I'm on the
second set as well and so explain this
to me it Powers up the master sword you
return the Master Sword to its pedestal
and you go through this like almost
really difficult event tide island or no
like a wave modes kind of uh Cave of
Trials if you play Twilight Princess
yeah you go through like a series of
rooms and you kind of have to clear each
room but they uh introduce different um
challenges each room um and there's like
little breaks where you can stop and
cook and um like get you know a pair of
pants and it's like yes finally got
pants yeah and like you have no armor so
you're doing it naked hearts and you can
die in one hit there's like bomb arrows
and what you cook and how you cook it is
like super key and I found um when I was
doing the last you know of the three
sets of these trials you know you finish
one of these sets kind of exit the
trials and you could take a little break
which is like your checkpoint really um
but yeah the last one I like screwed up
where I was just I was cooking a Hardy
truffles or something like that and I
and I cooked like three at once no which
was real dumb so that means that I
basically didn't have like three lives
really like where I'm able to like
recover all my hearts plus some sorry
hold on wait why was that detrimental
because one hearty truffle will give you
all your heart all your hearts but would
wouldn't they already be cooked for
later years the other two no cuz he
combined combined them all oh yeah
you're dumb that's stupid now I get it
sorry hey man I still got through it uh
but yeah so you and you know you're
you're some some of these floors are
Elemental based so you're like being
really okay well maybe I'll like spread
out these Peppers so I can have like you
know a series of different like U um
immune um Buffs to like immunities thank
you to like um the cold environment uh
yeah so you just you know you're you're
kind of like you know play really
conservative and cautiously if you got
really into a ventide island how similar
is this it's very very similar okay um
but these you know this ramps up like
with armor and and cooking and stuff
like that like you're not doing as much
cooking and stuff on the other ones
you've got to be really clever with your
environment as well and like your
positioning and how you use various
items like you might not notice that
there are these explosive barrels on
this one little platform but if you get
to them that'll
take out two enemies and set the other
one on fire and like things like that
you have to pay pay attention to which
um this is probably not the right time
to segue but if you think about what it
takes to really succeed in master mode
it's those sort of clever um you know
Maneuvers and tactics before we do get
into Master mode I want to talk that was
what was interesting to me about this
you said you can kind of use the
environment I wasn't aware that you
would be able to just like sneak up on
these camps I thought they were going to
spawn you in with four guys staring at
you already that can happen that can
definitely happen does happen there are
opportunities for stealth yeah this one
um this like this is the first level of
the first section um this one like it
you can go there's several options which
is cool like you can go um sneak up and
grab their weapons or like I just like
threw a bomb and killed them all in
one uh and then you can take time
there's like uh you really want to
explore the environment before you move
on to the next level which is cool um
because you want to gather like Rob was
saying like if you have you know if you
need uh you know spicy peppers
to survive one area you really want to
gather everything you can so like on
this level if you climb one of the trees
there's bird eggs right and you really
want those cuz those are going to give
you a huge boost when you're cooking
kind of in the middle of these levels
you know what's a bummer is that help
you like a crow I swear only on this
floor there was a bird egg and a tree
and I spent so much time on every other
floor with trees looking and I've never
found another there's one there's one
other there's one other nest and another
one but there's also like a hidden
treasure chest that you have to like if
you successfully killed uh the right
enemies there's one with like fire choo
choos that's a big one and if you let
them burn the grass you can uh get a
like turn your arrow into a fire arrow
and then burn a platform and a treasure
chest will fall down and if yeah or just
catch the wind and ride it up yeah
exactly that could be yeah definitely
but if you if you kill all of those guys
those fire tissues then you can't get
the chest so like they'll kind of like
tease you with like oh you got to hold
on to an enemy or maybe want to hold on
to an Archer and get more arrows and let
him um
I was laughing Eric green had a Pete
Brown comment most important question
how much like Zelda breath
wild yeah but it's it was tough like
there I think you guys are on um the
middle trials where there's like kind of
like a theme of basically pitch black so
you can't see anything oh okay it's
so tough and so you know they basically
just reiterate on that uh for like five
floors until it's like a guardian yeah
and you're fighting a guardian the Pitch
Black it's it's like freaking tough so
I'm curious you said okay so you there's
two checkpoints in the full trials and
then you finish it yeah so there's the
first set it's like 14 floors or
whatever then you are uh launched back
to the Lost Woods then there's second
yeah and the sword's back the swords
upgraded like 10 um Power and then
there's the second set same thing
happens and then there's the the final
okay and the final will give you uh the
item level of 60 and I've been using
that sword and it has ceased to run out
of energy so it's like basically yeah
all you need it doesn't run out as far
as it feels more like the actual Master
Sword I would imagine okay cuz I was
wondering if like maybe it was something
like the you know like the Helen Shield
has like a 90 item level and eventually
all break I was wondering if maybe this
this is the end game like this little
thing right here right that was the next
question is if for someone who I don't
know how many hours I played of the game
I think I'm at the point where I could
play this but uh this is the most of the
DLC is meant for people who have put a
substantial amount of time into breath
of the wild right except for the
equipment that's hidden in highroll
field I feel a lot of that stuff is
really good for new players Coro
especially like the cororo mask no no
Majora's Mask dude cuz does most
monsters won't attack you unless you
attack first like lower level um it's
like the monster masks but they're not
specific to like yeah you get that in
master mode well the DLC you can so but
you actually I think for one or two of
the things you actually have to get the
you have to beat one of the the the
dungeons
okay before you're allowed to get one of
the maybe it's the whole set I don't
know oh are you talking about The
Travelers one The Travelers that might
be Travelers you have to have gone
through the Labyrinth but you don't like
if you've already done it you can just
fast travel there sure no no yeah yeah
there was some something I was reading
though in one of the somebody's guide
was saying you can't get one of the
items until you you beat like mea's
dungeon oh you're absolutely right yeah
yeah yeah um yeah we didn't even talk
about the mask I do want to talk about
the cororo mask though because um um you
know that can be kind of cool if you
didn't get a lot of chox seeds and you
want to try like having more item slots
it's also extremely helpful for the
trials um to have a ton of item slots
cuz if you're Gathering like as much as
possible you want to you know like there
was one level where my weapon broke and
then I didn't have a weapon and I had to
scr for one um so it can help with that
it's also really helpful if you're just
starting the game and you want to go get
the Coro mask and it'll alert you to
where the Coro are so I put like 75 80
hours into breath of the wild
hypothetically I can just load it up
today having bought the DLC downloaded
and just go to the to the pedestal put
the sword back in you
have so but you you really need to have
done enough shrines like Peter I think
you I don't know how many hearts you had
but I have like four or five in the
second row and I had to trade in a bunch
of stamina to get that so I only have
one and a half stamina Wheels how many
shrines have you done you need I think
I'm missing a few dozen so okay yeah
yeah I I so I did this after completing
all the Shrine so I I like I think I'm a
little overpowered even um but it does
get much more challenging like the first
run is is not too challenging um you can
die in one hit even with that many
hearts um especially when you get to the
later stages of that but so like I don't
know it's not going to be too easy if
you did complete all the shrines but
yeah you're going to want to have a
couple more Hearts than you start out
with and you need them to get the master
sword anyway unless you're like that
psycho who beats it on Master mode with
three hearts and just devotes all the
stuff to stamina right yeah so I love
that because he hadiz he had the hearts
but he gave him up he had to have gotten
the hearts and then traded them back in
which get because you need how many to
get the sword 12 12 or 13 yeah yeah um
yeah like all in all but I do want to
get first off I want to talk about last
week in terms of uh I have a few amiibo
stories and by that I mean I watch Rob
pull his hair out because Nick Margarita
like on his first or third try got we
have the uh they released that new
Majora's mask link amiibo and he's
holding he's holding the Goron mask the
actual amiibo but yeah people are using
amiibo and you can reload if you don't
how many amiibo can you use a day three
you can you can use once a day once a
day like the the same amiibo once a day
but if you reload a previous save it
doesn't you have to soft reset basically
you can get the best like you can get
the fierce da link sword mask or uh
tunic and then if you don't get it you
can reload the save and then once you
get it you could save it so you can get
the other stuff the next day uh we're
looking at that right now oh man it
looks pretty sweet but Rob was having
difficulty with this because I we don't
know what the actual chances are it was
the Twilight bow I wanted the Twilight
bow oh Twilight bow is the one that just
shoots light arrows right oh my God it
has infinite arrows seems kind of oh it
does yeah yeah that sounds like the game
would be easy yeah oh I hate when she
does this the fairies are so creepy I
think what Pete lives for when he plays
smooch me um okay cool equipment outside
of major okay so how does Majora's Mass
not make Master mode like a piece of
cake if you find it you can't well I
mean you'd have to use the amiibo all
over again you don't take any of this
stuff into Master mode so I don't know
no what I'm saying you get into Master
mode and then you find Majora's Mask the
actual mask iname right but that's what
I was saying before is that you'd have
to beat a dungeon you'd have to be
capable of D meas dungeon okay right
whether it's meas or another one yeah
there's like one dungeon so there still
be a trek to get that in the first place
yeah like having played Master mode on
the weekend um that makes more sense cuz
yeah Peter uh like it was weird like the
side Quest that you would you know you
would get immediately uh playing like
normal if you were far enough this all
came at once but like only a couple were
unlocked um when I started Master mode
and master mode you know the enemies
have they're not just stronger they
don't just hit harder and take more
damage their health regenerates they can
see you coming from a lot farther away
oh yeah I forgot their health
regenerates that is brutal that is yeah
it is brutal how quickly do you have to
take down a liony in order I haven't
even let alone of let alone of boblin
honestly like first boblin which is also
from a red to a blue level uh I I I
wasn't able to kill so I like it yeah
Peter and I on the stream last week uh
we just tried it like for a few moments
and yeah we died twice immediately
because you know you think oh well you
know you got to do flurry Rush well when
you're doing flurry rush you can easily
launch him and I think it happens in
this video here launch him really far
away giving him more time to regen his
health yeah oh damn or like recharges
that fast yeah really fast um so so the
thing is is when you first start off
again it's you know you're it's not just
like your hearts it's also like the type
of weapon you have so I was like just
screw it I'm like I'm moving so what I
was realizing over the weekend with
Master mode is I I found the game to
like all its like core systems to kind
of like get pulled up as far as like
right now like I'm more inclined to like
push Boulders off a cliff just to get a
better weapon and then run um and
stealth is like a must meaning like the
shika uh stealth gear um you want to use
and sneak up on guys or sneak just past
them like a lony like hell no there are
lels everywhere in the world too in
master mode like really right in the
first uh this is the great Plateau like
there's one like right around the corner
oh Jesus you're just like all right no
way there's not a chance it's not it's
worth your time I think the the I like
the ramifications of that because not
only are you using stealth and avoiding
enemies if you don't have monster Parts
you can't make Elixir so you're going
through the game without Elixir if you
can't Farm liels like you can't upgrade
a lot of your armor like you're you're
going to be really set back in a lot of
different ways and I think it highlights
I mean the same thing that even TI
island or the trials of the sword
highlight the the um attention they put
into making you know everything in the
game interconnect and like you can
interact with everything and you you
know the rules of the the world um I
like that you have to use the boulders
instead of just kind of charging in yeah
and there you know there are other ones
too like you could do stasis on like a
metal box and take out a guy um they
have like the world is filled with that
type of stuff you know explosive
explosive barrels um one thing actually
that I forgot to tell you guys that I
found out uh the hard way is that and I
find this a little Overkill there's no
Auto saves really there's only there's
only two manual saves dang so sorry you
can save any time but there's only two
slots with which to do so yeah right
meaning you you need to manual save like
if I think the Witcher was kind of like
that you could easily screw yourself
over oh totally or you know you think
about if it was meant to like make the
game harder and make you you know you
got to be saving a lot more but I think
about so many times where the Autos
saves have been clutch when I when I
screwed up and did something weird and
dumb you know what I mean where it's
like I don't know I went to the wrong
spot or I like I like I dropped or lost
my uh Helen Shield like stop saying
Helen isn't it I'm sorry I suck
karaoke Village Dorito Village Koke
vocabulary in this game is just nothing
like mine yeah whatever but you know
what I mean like you the high and shield
you like you lose
that that's a thousand rupees I think
like it's just that sucks like what you
don't buy the high well you can
eventually you once once you get it oh
from the guy in uh Terry town you can go
back and buy it didn't you call it tney
Town once I sure did torney town I think
the voices in my hay in my head they say
whatever they want but anyways and then
there there are also lifts around here
if you see the like these guys on lifts
oh yeah I forgot that was going to be a
thing kind of dumb I thought so too I
don't like the sky guys so I was on the
same page but I actually saw something
neat where like uh I was walking by a
camp and there was one on the ground and
when they saw me they raised it yeah oh
that's pretty cool which kind kind of
made more sense opposed to just these
dudes floating in air with a chest like
I just what's the reason for that in the
world that's like uh in Mad Max Fury
Road when they raised that platform so
none of the people can get up to where
the AA Cola is I don't like those
floating
platforms oh here's no it's like up get
that Pixar I love Pixar not Zelda here's
an example of something that was real
crappy so I was like okay that octar
rock balloon is pulling with all its
money help need somebody you guys don't
you have any decency help so here so
here I thought and I wonder this is I
think another like really tough moment I
was like okay I'll save here and I'll
try to get this chest because if you
know this ice cold water can kill you
instantly so I was like all right I'll
just walk back I got this in the bag
sploosh sploosh and then I reload the
save if you're listening to this later
in iTunes Rob just died cuz he fell into
the water that he just was talking about
and so now you go back and what was the
bummer was that um W this is great
gameplay anyways the bummer uh the
bummer part about it is that uh the
chest wasn't there MH what yeah I didn't
I didn't understand that wait that
happens sometimes like have you ever
gone Dragon farming and you like the
best verb
ever sorry sorry uh so yeah this game is
just hold on hold on Dragon farming what
if you uh if you like uh make a campfire
and go tell morning the dragon will
appear but if you like reload the save
because you like accidentally Farm the
wrong part or something the dragon won't
be there like I think that happens in
this game with a lot of different things
for some reason you're dead what are you
doing I'm fine dude yeah um yeah so in
all all in all it seems like the most
appealing part of uh Master mode for me
is like what you guys mention it
emphasizes rather than the it emphasizes
exploration but in a different way it's
through survival right it's you are kind
of picking and choosing your battles a
little more wisely I would like to
imagine or at least I think I would uh
you're moving through this High rule at
a slower Pace does it make you this is
going to sound kind of like uh dramatic
does it make you connected to this H
roll in a different way than you
originally were so dramatic dud I I
thought so that's what like kept me like
wanting to play it more uh was how how
you felt you know as as you did in the
uh first like I want to say a couple
dozen hours of the game just scared
terrified of like a thunderstorm um it's
kind of like reliving that again but
even more D dramatic and you know at
first thought was thinking like well why
wasn't this this mode like with the game
uh upon launch but oh cuz they could
sell it later on for more money well
that obviously but but there was
something coming back to it having
played so many hours where like uh you
understand the systems and like what to
do um like much greater than like I
think if you were to play it like
immediately well think about it too this
is a massive world and we've already
stated that they reconfigured the
layouts of enemies and stuff like that
so more than just ramping up dialing up
numbers right it's so why it wasn't
included that might be a reason they had
to actually refine like okay what is
Master mode how do we create these
challenges in the world that feel like
they've been you know crafted by hand
yeah it's so weird that we're talking
about DLC and a Zelda game but it seems
like the the model they have is working
right the next one comes out in uh
holiday December uh that's something of
the Champions Ballad of the Champions
bad and you know it's focusing more on
oh names daroo
mea uh who's a gudo lady does anybody
remember her
namea
and ravali yeah the the coolest one the
cocki the dickest yeah yeah um it seems
like that was that going to be more
story focused or like going back
entirely story focused that's a new
dungeon too new amiibos like a fifth
like uh ancient beasti kind of dungeon I
don't think it's confirmed that it's
like a Divine Beast Divine Beast sorry I
mean like in terms of like a fullon
dungeon not a shrine it's like a prequel
isn't it I sincerely hope so I mean
talking about experiencing hyru with a
different perspective in the in master
mode I really want to be able to see
something of what it was like I mean you
get that with memories um but I I would
love to experience like prequel I just
want to be ring we know what happens we
know it all goes to yeah let's see
it go to yeah I mean it's that that
battle right like that battle the big
it's the reach of Zelda sure exctly Halo
Reach that's yeah you know the outcome
yes which is more difficult in my
opinion than just coming up with a new
maybe not I don't know um I just want to
be ravali and go around and hook up with
birds I don't know that you actually get
to play with those characters I know but
that's what I want okay um yeah so that
comes out later this holiday uh it seems
to me like Master mode is more like uh
Fallout 4 survival mode uh Far Cry
Primal did the same thing where night
was even more dangerous uh ammo was not
as plentiful the actual Predators were
kind of more aggressive yeah Dishonored
hard mode or like Ranger mode again in
Metro and I like it's one of those games
where I don't know do you feel like
Master mode is something you'll keep
playing in the future if you if like if
it wasn't DLC is it's the way you prefer
to play the game
now yeah and that's what's kind of a
bummer is like having just done the
trials it's like I got the sword now
what what do you do with it like I I
beat the game
like I I would it be better mid game to
do the master trials if you could or
trial sword I think so I think I mean
like probably it would probably make a
lot of things easier for you I I would
love to be able to carry what I have
over into Master mode it's like I put
all that effort into getting a fantastic
sword and I've already beaten the game
but I am excited to switch the voices to
Japanese yeah they had that I think an
update or two ago I hav tried it but you
couldn't do it mid game so I'm excited
to start Master oh co I think I'm
assuming you can do it in I finally did
that in Persona 5 got the DLC for the
Japanese voice acting yeah they're the
English the voice actors with what they
were given were actually really good oh
yeah I mean English things would never
come out of someone's mouth sakam Samo
um yeah I think the the English vas uh
for a lot of Japanese made things like
have interesting things to work with um
that might not translate as well um but
I don't know I just really don't want to
hear Zelda's English
accent Link Link um what was I going to
say yeah I just found out this morning
that McCree from OverWatch Leon from res
Evil 6 and Y kidawa from Persona five
the same voice actor Matthew Mercer um
side tangent but it was actually
applicable for once um cool any last
thoughts on Master mode Trials of Sword
DLC well worth the money it sounds like
if you played a lot of Zelda so far I
mean technically it's $10 right uh no
you you can't buy it for 10 you have to
pay 20 so you so I'm just saying but
you're going to get $10 more worth of
content down the road like I don't know
I know what you're say all three in that
you have you can't yeah you can't just
spend 10 you're right the bummer but I
think yeah I think it's great I mean if
you really like that game I think
there's enough here uh but I think
Master mode is where it's really at so
all three of you right now are locked
into you already paid for the ballot of
the Champions as well cuz it's a $20
pack with the two waves of DLC cool uh I
have to get into that I have not yet I'm
still finding areas that I haven't seen
before that was the coolest thing I was
like huge cave I was like oh my god I've
never seen this you not found all the
Coro seeds godamn so that's what you do
man that's how you keep playing the game
yeah I do we didn't talk about heroes
path mode it's very cool it's like there
I mean you had a really funny tweet
where you kept dying even tied yeah even
tied um I didn't realize it showed your
path up until when you activate it yeah
200 hours 200 hours it went pretty far
back you'll but you'll activate it when
you get the DLC it'll show you
everywhere you went up to that point I
thought it was once you start it doesn't
it's been tracking basically you're
reing it did you guys find it really
hard to go back to the beginning of the
timeline it's got finicky controls I
thought yeah it took me a second and
then I figured out how to do it um but
yeah I think I still had like half the
time left or something but I put in my
switch says I have 130 hours in Zelda
which is so I think it doesn't track
like when you're maybe standing still so
all the time accounted for shopping and
conversations cooking all that oh sure
but it's it's cool because you can
easily see this yeah here we go here's
here's ra on oh yeah I did remember this
to be honest die link
goes to be quite honest when I first saw
this the beginning of this this thing
you tweeted I thought you were trying to
draw something on even tide that was
before I realized he's drawing a gnome
yeah um P drawings on the reddits it it
would have been really helpful when I
was looking for the remaining shrine
shrines I think like when I had 10
shrines left I was
really uh scraping the bottom of the
barrel it would have been cool to see
what areas I'd missed which is the best
part of Heroes path um and there is an
entire area where like I just haven't
been on foot and I was like oh I better
go over there there's probably a lot of
scx seeds and a liony probably yeah yeah
it's it's a cool feature because yeah
there are so many times where you
because the map is just so condensed you
just see something but I'll come back to
it and then you forget or like yeah
Peter you were saying like straight up
shrines that you would go to
and then move along like just leave him
just leave him yeah MH yeah someone was
mentioning it was kind of odd that so
presumably the Data Tracking movement
was there before the DLC but now they're
choosing to implement it for the DLC but
like you would mention I think this was
a Twitter conversation I kind of evees
dropped on someone else just brought it
up in the chat like right now actually
yeah yeah uh Apex penguin was just
saying that on YouTube I think it's
weird that breath of wild has been
tracking your movement the whole time
even before the DLC it's a different
case when you actually implement it
right for Hero's path or is that a like
some people were wondering why didn't
they just imp imp that in the beginning
maybe they didn't think it was worth it
until they had a model for it that made
sense or maybe the DLC just wasn't big
enough and they figured like okay we'll
find something else to put in there yeah
who knows really I don't think it's
Sinister yeah it is such a minor feature
too it's not really like that big of a
carrot to well speak for yourself I'm
boycotting Nintendo stuff now oh no just
kidding yeah they were farming all your
data and selling it yeah um cool so that
was uh Master mode and trials of sword
in Zelda's master of Trials DLC for
breath of the Wild mhm yeah uh you can
go download that now it's $20 but you'll
have that and then you'll have the
ballot of the Champions later on this
year and we have a lot more in-depth
stuff on Gamespot if you want to go
check that out uh that's our show for
today kind of a lighter week than normal
we were going to talk about law Breakers
but uh Jean Luke and Jake were the ones
playing on PC last week uh we thought I
thought I'd saw cliff bazinsky tweet
that it was going to be on PS4 last
weekend which would have been great cuz
I had a lot of time to play games but it
was not I prefer to play it on PC out I
it was think so maybe was but I never
got the maybe I signed up too late but
it was an open Beta so I figured I would
have gotten the invite yeah but um yeah
I'm going to play more on PC maybe we'll
talk about that next week because that
game is actually kind of sneaking up in
a good way um August 8th it'll release
and I'm looking forward to it because
it's kind of like a blend between you
know people are comparing to OverWatch
but it's like Quake Champions mixed with
OverWatch uh really fast-paced uh zero g
OverWatch um more of a shooter I think
it's been like a kind of tactical thing
like a lot of vertical movement which
yeah uh I'm looking forward to playing
more of that we talked about it last
week we were talking about games left
for the summer I heard in the zero the
zero g Parts you can like immediately
turn behind and shoot behind you and
actually kind of do like the the Quake
Rocket Jump yeah like you can like gain
speed shooting behind you see that's
what I I want cuz I played a lot of phoh
when I first started playing OverWatch
because she had like a rocket jump so
I'm excited yeah she was like the Quake
the Quake kind of character and I played
a lot of of that when I was a kid so I'm
excited for law Breakers I wasn't for a
long time
yeah I was I was watching like John Luke
try some of the new classes like these
look super interesting because I played
a decent amount of it in the Clos beta
or Alpha they did uh last year when they
still had like three or four classes but
uh there's a bunch there's like a new
medic I haven't tried there is a there's
one with like a dual with a pistol that
also has like a kind of knife right
under it for Quick Melee attacks I
forget what he's called Jean Luke would
know but uh yeah you should check these
The Wraith thank you Sean Luke umth yeah
this game looks really fun it was fun my
play I think John Luke and Jake enjoyed
it but uh we do want to talk about that
more next week if possible although the
betas might be over but again it's
coming out semi soon August 8th uh later
in the summer it's only a month away
damn we're moving through the summer
fast uh cool what do you Pete what do
you playing the rest of the week Zelda
yeah Zelda pretty much it's a really
light time of the year for reviews but
um I might pick something up we'll see
what's out there yeah so always good to
keep reviewing games yeah yeah we talked
about playing Battlegrounds getting
getting more into that one I need to
play to do that yeah yeah we should do
that just stream it oh you you two
bringing back Triforce tomorrow you're
going to start playing through Master
mode is that going to run for a few
weeks until you beat Master mode or
something if you're going to beat Master
mode I think I think the plan is we'll
start slow and see how it goes um and
then I think I'm willing to like play
maybe on my own time and like start
making some skips M uh if needed to go
an interesting like challenges that you
can come up with and St right because I
think part of it right now again is like
you're just avoiding enemies and you got
to focus on shrines so maybe I'll like
knock out a handful of shrines on my own
time mhm Kelly what are you playing same
thing um I started The Witcher 3 finally
oh jez I have tons of things to play and
I did that which is dumb um you're
coming up on the 10th anniversary of the
first Witcher in
early September yeah uh other than that
I think I'm going to prioritize near
over Persona 5 just because I think I
can get through near more quickly I've
been wanting to play that um so that's
probably what I will tackle this weekend
mhm I want to go see Spider-Man oh I'm
seeing Iron Maiden tonight oh yeah the
fan I remember hearing that last week
they're still alive yeah they're they
were in La over the weekend my dad was
going to go um and uh they're doing a
mobile game so I'm going to check out
going to check out the mobile game and
see that's so funny what is an iron
madeen mobile game like I don't know
hold on are you saying MOA or mobile
mobile not MOA no it might be a
MOA dope I don't knowa
mobile Iron Maiden face off against
Black
Sabbath and Ries are the creeps Eddie is
like your main character yeah anyway so
I'm looking that all right uh yeah like
I mentioned the giveaway earlier we have
that Spider-Man uh Funko plushy Disney
Infinity black suit Spider-Man and the
Fig Daily Bugle I don't know upside down
black and white Spider-Man I don't know
how to describe that uh yeah if you
follow Gamespot on Twitter just retweet
that tweet uh Shiva will have put it up
and then it should link to our actual
giveaway we'll pick winners randomly
later in the week if you don't follow
Gamespot do so please and uh yeah we'll
uh reach out to you later in the week uh
in the meantime yeah we have Triforce
tomorrow we have streams pretty much
every day at 11 o'clock Pacific now damn
right yeah um Jake and I will be doing
one on Monday I think we'll probably be
playing Metro cuz that's what we talked
about the last reboot episode we're
trying to like kind of follow up on that
but yeah Jo are doing a thing on Friday
it's very exciting Joey and Jean Luke
are playing what are you guys playing
should I can I talk about it John Luke
sure what is it uh we're playing uh
dealer No Deal oh yeah so you in in an
increasingly
uh there's an increasing frequency in of
which uh Joey y will just do weird
things he's a he's a masterclass
poster so what he did was he bought I
think 33 copies of Deal or No Deal D DS
but like half of them were the special
edition but there was nothing different
it just said special edition yeah there
was nothing different about it the back
description is the same um and they are
gonna play that and there's going to be
I think fun surprises so check it out
cool uh so that'll be Friday short week
for us here but we're kind of already
back on schedule but uh yeah as always
for more Zelda stuff for more uh if you
want to go read Pete's crash insane
Trilogy and yell at him uh and just in
general maybe we'll find out more about
star wars's progression system closer we
get to Battlefront 2's November launch
but as always thank you for stopping by
we'll see you the same time next week
[Music]
later
e